mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
die ehe hochgelobt für tot erklärt und
wiederbelebt musiker stark prägt vor dem
sogenannten romantische lebenskonzept
dort der ekstase
weltnummer 3
bisher war sie nur mann und frau
vorbehalten
jetzt könnte sich das in der schweiz
ändern
sie wird ganz offensichtlich nicht durch
die veränderte offensichtlich gibt es
das bedürfnis zur und wie hat sich die
ehe als erfolgreichste partnerschaft
etabliert welche rolle spielt sie heute
noch und was ändert sich wenn auch
gleichgeschlechtliche paare heiraten
können jetzt im kultur platzen
[Musik]
willkommen auf dem kulturplatz heute
machen wir station in meret oppenheim
vodafone base hier ist die erste us
kultur zu hause und damit auch wir vom
platz
[Musik]
und das wollen wir heute über die
institution der ehe nachdenken und
weshalb wir eigentlich immer noch so
unbeirrt an sie glauben trotz enormer
scheidungsrate ende september stimmen
wir darüber ab obwohl die ehe für alle
möglich sein soll und damit nehme die
geschichte der erde bereits eine
wechselvolle ist eine neue wendung
laura und delia bonito sind seit drei
jahren ein paar und leben in einer
eingetragenen partnerschaft sie wollen
kinder und würden gerne heiraten doch in
der schweiz können sie das nicht
weniger
noch
um kinder zu kriegen weichen sie
momentan ins ausland aus denn der zugang
zusammen banken ist in der schweiz für
lesbische paare verboten und kommt das
kind auf die welt dann kann nur einer
der beiden frauen mutter und elternteil
sein
[Musik]
wenn ich selbst war prägend für
das jahre unterstellen dass sie
adoptiert
das heißt sie muss für die restlichen im
lebenslauf schicken
[Musik]
eine ehe für alle würde das ändern
lesbische ehepaare bequemen zugang zu
schweizer samenbanken und wären abgebot
beide rechtlich die mütter
zwei mütter oder zwei väter als ehepaare
und eltern dagegen wehrt sich das nein
lager es sieht die traditionellen werte
der ehe gefährdet und sorgt sich um das
wohl der kinder
[Musik]
geborgenheit geben aber sie können eine
verständlich dass sitzungen spätestens
in der pubertät will das kind wissen wo
sind meine wurzeln hier finde ich wäre
es umso wichtiger weil den eltern nicht
dort wo das kind von geburt er aufwächst
beide geschlechter vorhanden sind das
ist ein mehrwert für das kind weil sie
sich ergänzen
[Musik]
bisher war die geschichte der ehe immer
eine zwischen mann und frau ihre
fortpflanzung ein fester bestandteil
davon was wenn sich das ändert was hieß
es für die ehe wenn paare nur ein
geschlecht haben
die historikerin carolina nie hat sich
immer wieder mitte ehe und ihrer
bedeutung beschäftigt in ihrem klassiker
entzwei jungen beschrieb sie die
vorstellungen von der ehe im neunzehnten
jahrhundert
als zentrales bar
und frau und tätig geschlechterdifferenz
ich absolut zentral und kennen sie
eigentlich
sollte die materielle realisation vor
ort
ja genau und hat ist das natürlich ganz
verstehen und davon getrunken
aber wenn das nicht biologisch ich
stelle mir geschehen
als arnies buch erschien wurde die
eingetragene partnerschaft für
homosexuelle eingeführt ein erster
schritt auch die ehe anders zu denken
der effekt eröffnung ihres technik vor
die institution ehe aus von richtig gut
das ist das wo etwas ist das man würde
im historisch blick gerade die ganze
tiefgreifende für anträge was hacker
hatte zurück führt das ist gegenüber
gibt
sollen dass sich auf
die ehe hat sich immer wieder gewandelt
mal als solidargemeinschaft gedacht um
sich gegenseitig zu unterstützen
nachkommen zu zeugen und sich dann im
alter durch kinder abzusichern
dann ersetzt durch die heute verankert
romantische liebe ehe mit ihrem anspruch
auf tod und ewigkeit
[Musik]
vor dem sogenannten romantische
lebenskonzept tod ekstase forever number
two und die
passion oder liebe als passion und der
punkt ist dass in der moderne und das
lebenskonzept miteinander verschränkt
und
das ist vorher in gruppen voneinander
und ich danke dir eine verschlankung und
irgendwie und er muss eigentlich
solidargemeinschaft das nach vorn
ökonomisch
unzählige konzerte nah beieinander
und doch das ehrliche versprechen
inklusive kernfamilie monogamie und
kinder ist ein dauerhaftes erfolgsmodell
die nachkommenschaft das biologische
frucht heterosexuelle liebe das ist tief
in der gesellschaft verankert obwohl das
nach helfen wenn es um kinder geht eine
lange tradition hat
der erste kommentiert von eine
künstliche befruchtung gemacht himmel
ist so an die 80 runden denn ein stau
die freiwilligen hintergrund wenn man
das konzept hätte es rentiert gemacht
hatte ist jetzt der arzt auf worten
verdammt wurde das kind mit gemacht
dass ich das zeigt dies alles verändere
der konzeptionen
heute steht mit der
fortpflanzungsmedizin dem kinderwunsch
nichts mehr im weg egal wie viele
geschlechter daran beteiligt sind doch
in der schweiz ist es für lesbische
paare schwer kinder zu bekommen so auch
für laura und die la bonita
deutschland wird es erlaubt
seine bank ausgesucht und
entspannt
sozial ist
für die schweiz sind für die sache
doch überfordert
mit der ehe für alle wäre es einfacher
doch sie bleibt umstritten
ich finde es ist falsch den kinderwunsch
der erwachsenen dem wohl des kindes über
zuordnen denn dem kind wird beim lebens
staat ohne not eine hypothek mit gegeben
nämlich dass es seinen biologischen
vater nicht kennen kann und dass kein
männlicher elternteil in der familie ist
braucht es zwei geschlechter für die
erziehung
wie wichtig ist es für kinder ihre
biologischen ursprünge zu kennen wie
definieren wir kindeswohl und damit
zusammenhängend familienglück und gute
elternschaft
politisch klasse deine frage stehe und
die konfrontieren wir verstehen ihre
scharfen verstand vaterschaft ich
verstehe mich mutterschaft wir stark de
die wahl des vorstandes steht ja nicht
irgendwo gibt es nach durch seine user
finden und es steht also für die
gläubige stolz blickte texten aber
abermals eine landesgesellschaft und des
zivilrechts entsteht und das ist schade
dort erfolgt vom
politischen von politischer politischen
diskussion und auf den politischen
streit und das müssen wir uns heute
die ehre und alles was damit
zusammenhängt ist noch immer ein
kernanliegen in der gesellschaft wir
können entweder alternative
partnerschafts formen im gesetz
verankern oder wir öffnen die ehe und
leben mit dem wandel dieser institution
[Musik]
die ehe hat eine wechselvolle geschichte
hinter sich in der antike gab es bereits
gesetze denn damals diente eine heirat
vor allem der sicherung von macht und
das sicherstellung legitimer
nachkommen im frühen mittelalter dann
kam bewegung in die geschichte der ehe
und den europa war als die kirche die
diese vorantrieb
im frühen mittelalter war die ehe ganz
einfach ehe versprechen abgeben bei
schlafen und fertig die ehe war
vollzogen das war im dreizehnten
jahrhundert das erste mal überhaupt dass
eheleute selber entscheiden konnten ob
sie eine ehe eingehen wollten
inklusive göttlichen segen das weiß die
historikerin zu seiner burkhards die
sich mit der er seit dem frühen
mittelalter beschäftigt 250 konsens
geführt wurde vor der herzliche
jurisdiktion juristischen nötig ich sehe
dass sie sich gegenseitig dass er
versprach hand und wenn sie denn noch
der sogenannt vollzogen hand also die
schlafstatt worden da hätten hätte das
juristisch als nötige vollzog und
zeitgeist an das amt gekostet
diese neue freiheit führte aber auch zu
einigen konflikten
[Musik]
so ganz will hertha hat sich das nicht
wie häufig denn der
einheitlich sein das galt die vierte und
heizstoffe und der anderen seite hätte
ich gesagt mein gesehen hätte das falsch
verstanden
84 juristischen konflikt entstanden sind
die ganz große veränderung kam 300 jahre
später mit martin luther der reformator
veränderte die ehe grundsätzlich
zweifelte am zölibat und deklarierte
gott habe die menschen als sexuelle
wesen geschaffen und heiratete als mönch
gleich selbst den preis den man dafür
zahlte die sexualität durfte nur
innerhalb der ehe stattfinden alles
andere war verboten also gleichzeitig
für mehr
menschen legitim sexualität wolle und
hätte immer mehr legitim sexualität
konstruiert oder geschaffen und damit
herr reese potenzial für und sucht
käufer vorher ist das viel
unklarer gesehen sehr klar würde was
außerhalb der ehe geschah war jetzt und
sucht so wurde gleichgeschlechtlicher
sex massiv verfolgt
die reformatoren öffneten die ehe für
alle auch für priester doch sie wollten
ordnung sie führten eheregister ein und
er gerichte dabei waren sogar
scheidungen möglich denn die ehe war
kein gott gegebenes sakrament mehr
einbruch ist der einzige grund für
seitige und abwesenheit vom der partner
langfristig
böswilliges verlassen hat das kaiser ist
die funktion vor der ehe
rheine sexualität nicht erfüllt
es gab auch das delikt des frühzeitigen
beischlafs wenn das kind zb früher als
sieben monate nach der hochzeit auf die
welt kam wurde mit geburts ohren
nachgerechnet ob das sein konnte
ein problem wurde wenn wir fuhren
kirchgang sechs
keine davon dass er zunehmend zur
verurteilung
führt sie hans-peter nicht charakter von
apa sk sie sind sehr viel druck sie aber
im grund nur ist eigentliche problem
konstruiert wurde von der obrigkeit wo
führt bevölkerung problems ist von der
liebe war zwar die rede doch die kam
erst mit der ehe und nicht davor meinte
zumindest der reformator heinrich
bullinger
denn da richtig air partner erhält denn
ist er voraussetzung dafür dass es liebe
entwickelt und das tut sie denn
und mit levi ist voraussetzung dafür
dass mehr funktionieren de fer die
liebes ehe kommt erst im 18 jahrhundert
mit der romantik am französischen hof
legte man die libertinage ab und suchte
die einheit von mit hesse und eheleben
das bürgertum machte dann die liebe als
exklusiv angelegenheit zur maxime
gesetzt eigentlich über media setzt auch
über roman doric setzt mit der neuen
reise wird vom sportcenter jahrhundert
sind liebesgeschichte im bürgertum
energieforums in cattolica durchsetzt
wird sich als bürger nicht sein können
mehrere verhältnis gut leisten und es
ist offen aber
säkularisiert heilsversprechen also muss
man jetzt so glücklich
im diesseits glücklich werden das galt
aber nicht mehr für alle ende des
achtzehnten jahrhunderts führte man ein
examen 1 vor allem genug geld musste man
haben das hat die fatale folgen
das führt dann dazu dass im sport auch
zeit und im frühjahr nun seid ihr 100
europa wie die illegitime zahle also
zahlen ehelich geborene kinder
exportieren will immer weniger lust
möglichkeit kann hand durch
vereinigungsprozess für lotte
mit dem ausbau des sozialstaates und der
zivilehe wurde die liebe im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert zum standard wenn auch unter
klaren geschlechts und
machtverhältnissen
[Musik]
die vielen erst mit der sexuellen
revolution und mit ihr die männliche
entscheidungsgewalt
[Musik]
die ehe ist eine geschichte der
ausgrenzung
[Musik]
eigentlich zeigt begaben sich geschichte
dass es immer kalt monitor verhör wurde
es hat immer form von diskriminierung
sexueller orientierung
sozio ökonomischen hintergründe
ökonomische voraussetzungen
fremden die renitenten verhörer der mist
konfessionelle erst ein verbot immer ihr
gemeinsam verboten
und doch ist es also interessant jetzt
das neue jetzt an der punkt ist das
instrument war extrem heterosexuell
konnotiert ist und immer über
ausgeschlossen hat jetzt will sie die
schwelle überschritten
die nicht heterosexuelle partnerschaft
wäre eine weitere neue interpretation
dieser alt ehrwürdigen institution
die junge deutsche autorin shader kurz
sie würde den begriff des verliebtseins
am liebsten abschaffen und das wort
liebe gleich mit dazu zu oft würde diese
missbraucht um starre geschlechter
definitionen aufrecht zu erhalten sagt
sie nun hat sie ein buch geschrieben
über die liebe als politischen akt und
über ihren wunsch nach radikaler
zärtlichkeit
[Musik]
verliebte pärchen
sommerliche harmonie
traute zweisamkeit
bilder die uns überall begegnen shader
kurt traute leichtigkeit liebe nicht wir
leben in einer gesellschaft die von sich
ständig behauptet eine so liebende
gesellschaft zu sein und liebe begegnet
uns überall und in jeder werbung und in
jeder serie und dabei sind wir eine so
ich würde sagen kalte ungerechte oftmals
sehr berechenbare gewaltvoll der
gesellschaft eine gesellschaft die ihr
unbehagen bereitet weder kot
journalisten und studierte philosophin
aus ihrem unbehagen heraus hat sie ein
buch geschrieben
radikale zärtlichkeit warum liebe
politisch ist
und darin räumt sie mit althergebrachten
vorstellungen von der liebe auf
[Musik]
wenn ich über liebe spreche werden die
meisten menschen direkt an der liebe
zuneigung zwischen zwei menschen
innerhalb einer monogamen
exklusiven partnerschaft denken also es
gibt das einmal diese sehr krasse
priorisierung von romantischer hetero
liebe sowieso und diese erzählung habe
ja wirklich schon erfülle also im film
wie in der literatur und meistens sind
diese medialen repräsentation natürlich
auch aus einer gewissen männlichen
patriarchalen sicht und dann gibt es
noch mal das finde ich ganz besonders
schlimm auch diese ganzen erzählungen
der liebe als eine form von naturgewalt
etwas was über uns einbricht so als
würde das einfach ja von gott geschickt
und es kommt so über uns und wir können
uns eigentlich gar nicht wehren
statt für liebe plädiert trainer kurz
für mehr zärtlichkeit in unserer
gesellschaft
die viel beschworene romantische liebe
die in einer monogamen kernfamilie ihre
vollendung findet ist ein patriarch
alles konzept das vor allem dazu dient
männliche privilegien zu sichern
meistens frauen die total zerrieben
werden zwischen dem anspruch einer
lohnarbeit nachzugehen beim 1 ab
unabhängig zu sein von einem partner
aber gleichzeitig eben ja hausarbeit
kinder erziehen und so weiter und dass
das ganz oft gefragt wird als ein
vermeintlicher akt der liebe also frauen
machen dass er einfach weil das ihrer
weiblichen natur entspricht weil sie das
aus liebe zum partner und zu den kindern
machen und sie können ja einfach gar
nicht anders wie politisch liebe ist
erzählt jeder kurz entlang ihrer eigenen
biografie ihre eltern kommen aus der
türkei reiben sich auf für die familie
trennen sich die geschichten und filme
mit den shader kurt aufwächst lehren sie
das lieber nicht einfach im luftleeren
raum stattfindet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das mädchen mit einem roten kopftuch
oder eben auf türkisch zeit wie worden
das waren für mich sehr prägen also ich
komischer film erst mal der
türkischsprachigen filmgeschichte aber
auch darüber hinaus
repräsentiert dieser film eigentlich
sehr vieles was er mein anspruch
eigentlich ist in meinem buch und zwar
irgendwie zu erzählen dass liebe
politisch ist
[Musik]
assia hat die wahl zwischen romantischer
liebe und sicherheit und gewalt oder
fürsorge treue und verlässlichkeit
am ende entscheidet sich
gegen die romantik
[Applaus]
was ja
das ding ist es ja sicher zwischen zwei
männern entscheiden muss und diese
entscheidung ist ja für sie lebens
bestimmt und ich würde mir natürlich
eigentlich wünschen dass er sich
vielleicht gar nicht zu schließen wenn
dann entscheiden muss wie steht es um
unsere entscheidungsfreiheit in unserer
gesellschaft herrschten noch immer stark
enormen sagt jeder kurz und beschreibt
in ihrem buch wie und warum sie sich
schrittweise von der monogamie
verabschiedet hat
weil ich nicht einsehen wollte dass so
etwas wie zärtlichkeit oder zuneigung
oder liebe wie man es auch nennen möchte
nur auf einen menschen reduziert werden
soll also warum eigentlich
und habe ich irgendwie angefangen daran
zu zweifeln weil ich auch etwa eine
beziehung geführt habe die unfassbar
fair und wundervoll war aber ich
trotzdem das gefühl hatte aber warum
muss das exklusiv monogam sein und warum
kann beides nicht
dabei ist ihr klar dass sie privilegiert
ist und viele menschen existenzielle
sorgen haben als darüber nachzudenken
wie sie miteinander zärtlich sein
möchten dennoch fordert jeder kurt ein
umdenken von dem am ende alle
profitieren eine utopie ist eine
gesellschaft in der erst einmal alle
menschen die möglichkeiten und die
entscheidungsmacht haben darüber zu
entscheiden was für beziehungen sie
gerne leben würden auf welche art und
weise sie gerne zärtlichkeit erfahren
würden mit wie vielen menschen wo in
welchen räumlichkeiten
und in dem sinne dass es eine große
politische vielfalt von zärtlichkeit
gibt eine vielfalt die gleichermaßen und
gerecht geschützt ist
[Applaus]
von einer partnerschaft war die
künstlerin maria bello pro war ja mitte
dreißig meilenweit entfernt und doch
hatte sie den großen wunsch nach einem
kind in der schweiz und samenspenden für
alleinstehende frauen nicht erlaubt also
suchte sie nach einer anderen lösung und
darüber hat die künstlerin einen
eindrücklichen film gedreht ja ich habe
ethische moralische frage ich hatte sie
und habe sie nach wie vor
ich bin marine provider künstlerin
filmemacherin mutter einer tochter die
aus einer samenspende entstanden ist
die liebesbeziehungen die ich einging
war flüchtig keine gute basis um an
kinder zu denken
irgendwann wurde mir klar wenn ich
überhaupt noch kinder haben will dann
muss ich das selbst in die hand nehmen
die einzige möglichkeit die mir damals
zur verfügung stand ist entweder ins
ausland zu gehen und dort mich in einer
samenbank behandeln zu lassen oder das
privat auf eigene faust zu tun ich habe
zwei monate lang verschiedenen männern
geschrieben meinungen ausgetauscht und
habe mich dann für eine person letztlich
entschieden mit dem ich ins bett
gegangen bin mama
die akkus zu sehen
nun ist sie als
helden
hier wird babuschka warum ich auf eine
private samenspende zurückgegriffen habe
weil ich wollte dass meine tochter die
möglichkeit hat diese person kennen zu
lernen wenn sie das will
hier spricht man
sie haben mir gerade geschrieben und das
ist nämlich so also der vater von ellis
unbekannt also ich kann da nichts
ausfüllen auf diesem lohn formular
den film habe ich unserem leben entlang
gestaltet hat uns immer wieder gefehlt
unseren alltag gefilmt
[Musik]
ich war das hier machen darüber ein
versuch meine angst zu überwinden das
war eine flucht nach vorne
in dem moment wo ich aufstehe und sage
hey verdammt das ist nicht nur mein
problem das ist unser problem es gibt so
viele frauen in unserer gesellschaft sie
allein stehen sind die verrückt sind
nach ihrem job aber auch eine familie
haben wollen wie sich das verbieten weil
wir uns die ganze zeit ein bild
vorhalten von einer intakten familie dem
sie jemals entsprechen können
wir haben ja dieses hetero normative
modell so überladen mit erwartungen ist
super funktionieren ich als
heterosexuelle cis frau bekomme von dem
mann ein kind und denkmal muss ich auch
noch lieben und begehren ich muss mit
ihm mit dem haushalt gemeinsam
klarkommen mit dem kind klar kommen aber
auch unsere liebe und unsere sexualität
weiterleben können dass es nicht möglich
uns fehlen rollenbilder uns fehlen
bilder wie man das anders machen kann
wir konfrontieren von anfang an auch
unser umfeld damit meine tochter kommt
in die schule und sie reden dann über
familie wer lebt wie wer wohnt wege und
sie sagt sie wohnt mit ihrer mama
zusammen wir sind eine kleine familie
aber eigentlich hat sie 59 geschwister
[Musik]
wie sie damit in zukunft umgehen wird
ist nicht gesagt dass das genau so
harmonisch und selbstverständlich sein
wird wie das jetzt ist wo sie noch unter
meine elterlichen macht sozusagen lebt
und sich damit einfach mal einverstanden
erklären muss
[Musik]
liebe ihre kinder kriegen wie immer wir
diese themen leben sie sind so
individuell wie emotionsgeladen und was
immer wieder über die ehe denken sie ist
bis heute die vorherrschende
beziehungsform wer weiß vielleicht bald
für alle lebt war ende september wissen
wir wie die schweiz darüber denkt
nächste woche da zeigen wir ihnen das
resultat eines experiments und zwar
spielt das zürcher
jugendsinfonieorchester das berühmte
stück bolero und wir suchen dafür leihen
dirigenten vielleicht sind sie das
jedenfalls drehen wir dieses experiment
kommenden sonntag ab 16 uhr beim bahnhof
hardbrücke in zürich und ich würde mich
sehr freuen wenn sie mit dabei sind
gleich jetzt geht hier weiter auf sf1
mit der sternstunde philosophie kommen
sie gut durch die woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]